zu tun haben. Wie heißen Sie denn? Ich heiße Alma Schneider. Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und
Nachname langsam gestabilen? Ja, der Vorname ist ganz einfach A-L-M-A Alma und der Familienname ist
S-C-H-N-E-I, also E-D-E-R Schneider. Ich verstehe. Wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 78 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie
genau geboren? 1947. Wie viel wiegen Sie? Ja, ich wiege so 68 Kilo. 68, 68 Kilo. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 155. 155. Ein Meter 55. Hallo Frau Schneider, spreche ich Ihre Nachnamen richtig aus? Ja, das ist
meine Trauschen. Was führt Sie so uns? Ja, wissen Sie, meine rechte Hüfte tut mir mit einmal so wie
ich bin, ja, ich bin heute Nacht ein bisschen hingefallen, irgendwie auf dem Weg zur Toilette. Ich
glaube, ich bin über meinen Badeläufer gestolpert und ja, jedenfalls tut mir jetzt mein Bein B
und erst bin ich wieder ins Bett gegangen, heute Morgen bin ich auch aufgestanden, aber dann habe
ich gemerkt, ich kann nicht gut laufen und ja, dann habe ich noch gewartet. Wann sind Sie gestohnt? Ja,
gestern in der Nacht, irgendwann, was weiß ich, wahrscheinlich so zwei, drei Uhr, da muss ich
immer noch mal auf die Toilette gehen. Ja, und? Aber ich hatte schon geschlafen und war dann
wahrscheinlich nicht so richtig aufmerksam oder geblendet vom Licht, jedenfalls bin ich dann
gestolpert und hingefallen und ja, und jetzt merke ich doch, dass mein Bein ziemlich heftig wie
tut. Wenn ich still haltig geht, aber wenn ich versuche, das zu bewegen, tut es schon sehr, sehr weh.
Waren Sie da beustos? Ich glaube nicht, also ich bin halt alleine, also ich konnte wieder aufstehen,
das war zwar ein bisschen schwierig, ich musste mich an meinen Handgriffen an der Toilette und an der
Badewanne hochziehen, aber das hat geklappt und dann habe ich mich halt wieder in mein Bett verkrümmelt,
vor dem Stürzen hatten Sie irgendwelche Probleme, ist Ihnen aufgefallen oder? Ich war halt,
ich bin halt verschlafen gewesen und wie gesagt, das hat mich vielleicht das Licht im Badezimmer
ein bisschen geblendet oder so, ja, jedenfalls bin ich über meinen Teppich da gestolpert,
über den Badezimmer, hab ich da. Okay, ich verstehe. Wo sind Ihre Schmerzen? Könnten Sie bitte
da oben im rechten Bein, oben im rechten Bein tut es sehr heftig weh, es sticht und, und, und ja,
jetzt hab ich auch das Gefühl, ich kann eigentlich das Bein gar nicht richtig bewegen,
das fühlt sich auch so ein bisschen taub an, ja, erst habe ich das Bein, wahrscheinlich habe ich mir
einen blauen Flecke geholt oder irgendwie sowas, ne? Aber Sie können, Sie können gehen oder? Ja,
also wenn ich versuche zu gehen, tut es wahnsinnig weh, dann ist es richtig sehr schmerzhaft.
Wie stark ich mir sind auf einer Schmerzkala, wobei null gar keine Schmerzen und sehr stark
ich mir sind entspricht? Also wenn ich mich nicht bewege, das vielleicht so bei 3, 4, aber wenn
ich versuche, ja, ich hab halt jetzt irgendwie gar nicht mehr belastet, sondern hab nicht überall an
den, an den Möbeln abgestützt in der Wohnung, dass ich da gar nicht auf dem Bein auftreten muss,
ich hatte auch das Gefühl, das sagt mir so weg und, also dann sind die Schmerzen schon so bei 7,
7 oder 8 oder so, also schon richtig dolle Schmerzen, ja, das halte ich nicht aus und deswegen bin
ich auch ja hierher gekommen. Sind Sie an dem Möbel gestoßen? Richtig. Bitte? Sind Sie an dem Möbel
gestoßen? Nein, ich bin auf den Boden gefallen. Ich hab mich an den Möbeln festgehalten, wenn ich
jetzt in der Wohnung gelaufen bin, ne, damit ich das Bein nicht belasten muss, habe ich mich an,
am Stuhl festgehalten und an der Kommode und am Tisch, ja, damit ich nicht da drauf treten muss.
Okay, haben Ihre Schmerzen in der Lauf-Ederzeit verschlimmern oder verbessern?
Ja, verbessert sicherlich nicht, nee, nee, also als ich heute Nacht ins Bett gegangen bin,
habe ich gedacht, naja, gut, hast dich ein bisschen gestoßen, aber als es dann immer schlimmer
wurde und ich heute Morgen gemerkt habe, dass es irgendwie gar nicht, gar nicht besser wird,
ja, da habe ich halt gesagt, ich muss hier in die Klinik kommen.
Okay, ich verstehe. Strahlen Ihre Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus, oder?
Ja, eigentlich, ja, also das tut da alles weh, weil ich der Oberschenkel und bis in den Poran,
ich, wahrscheinlich habe ich da ja auch blaue Schlecken, ich habe das nicht so genau
angeguckt. Okay, ich verstehe. Und beim Ligen sind Ihre Schmerzen besser, besser.
Ja, also das ist zumindest erträglich, ja. Okay, ich verstehe. Und haben Sie irgendein
Problem, zum Beispiel, Linden Schmerzen oder Flanken Schmerzen oder Kenne Schmerzen?
Nee, nee, also das ist schon, also so, so, im Oberschenkel und ja, also in den Poran und
in die Hüfte so, ja, da tut es weh. Sind Sie ihre Kopf oder ihre Hauste gestoßen oder?
Nee, dann habe ich nichts, da bin ich nicht draufgefallen. Okay.
Und haben Sie irgendeine, haben Sie irgendeine andere Beschwerden?
Ja, also die Beschwerden langen wir völlig, das tut einfach saumäßig weh, ja.
Ja, okay. Haben Sie Übelkeit, Kopfschmerzen?
Nee.
Schwindelgefühl? Schwindelich?
Nein, nein, nein.
Oh, da, Boris Schmerzen, haben Sie Boris Schmerzen?
Nein, nein, mein Bein tut mir weh, der Oberschenkel wissen Sie, ja.
Okay.
Und also ich habe auch natürlich, dann, heute Morgen, als ich aufbewaffnet bin, habe ich
Tabletten genommen, Aspirin hatte ich dann noch gegen die Schmerzen, aber das hat überhaupt
nicht geholfen.
Okay.
Haben Sie in Ihrem rechten Hüfte irgendein öffentlicher Wunder, Wunder oder?
Belutung, Wunder?
Ich habe nicht so genau geguckt, also ich kann ja nicht so gut hingucken, wissen Sie,
ich bin eine alte Frau, aber ich glaube nicht, dass da eine offene Wunde ist, nein.
Also ein decken blauer Fleck ist da bestimmt ordentlich, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der Lesterzeit Schlagprobleme?
Ja, eigentlich habe ich keine besonderen Schlagprobleme und nachdem muss ich halt
manchmal auf die Toilette gehen, ja.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, in der Lesterzeit viel abzunehmen oder so genommen?
So, so zumindest?
Sie meinen, ob ich abgenommen oder zugenommen habe?
Ja, ja.
Halblich ist mein Gewicht immer ziemlich stabil, ich wüke mich jetzt auch nicht alle
paar Tage, aber eigentlich so diese, diese, das war es ich, diese, achten das sich
immer, ja.
Haben Sie Apotheosik, Apotheosik oder Apotheosik?
Nein, also das einzige, ja, was mir manchmal zu schaffen macht, wenn ich jetzt
etwas, was ich eine Treppe hochlaufe oder wenn ich, wenn ich viel sauber mache
in meiner kleinen Wohnung und mich da ein bisschen anstrengen, dann merke ich,
dass ich so ein bisschen außer Puste bin, ja, aber ja, wissen Sie,
in meinem Alter ist das ja normal, würde ich sagen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasser lassen oder Sturrgank?
Ja, nach dem Muss ich schon zwischendurch mal auf die Toilette, ja.
Also das kenne ich aber und das stört mich auch jetzt nicht so besonders.
Wie viel mal gehen Sie in der Nacht so Toiletten?
Ja, das kommt ein bisschen drauf an, also einmal bestimmen, manchmal auch
zweimal.
Kontrollieren Sie regelmäßig beim Frauenfrauenarzt?
Ja, also zu dieser Krebsvorsorge gehe ich halt schon immer noch hin, ja, ja.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Gegen Covid bin ich natürlich geimpft, das hat man damals ja all
alten Leuten empfohlen, ja.
Und was ich auch immer mache ist die Grippeimpfung, ja.
Auch Teternos?
Oh Gott, ich arbeite schon lange nicht mehr im Garten.
Und also gegen Teternos, das glaube ich schon lange her, dass ich da geimpft worden bin.
In der letzten 10 Jahre haben Sie keine Teternos empfohlen?
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergie?
Nein, ich bin nicht gegen nichts allergisch, wenn ich so überlege.
Ich wüsste nicht.
Nein, keine Allergie, bekannt, nein.
Haben Sie irgendwelche gegen eine Ernährung oder Essentintoleranz?
Ob ich irgendwas meinen Sie nicht essen mag?
Nicht mag oder nicht kann?
Ja, das ist ein Sie, Sie können vielleicht irgendwelche Essen nicht vertragen.
Doch, doch, ich kann alles vertragen. Mir schmeckt nur nicht alles, ja.
Ich bin ein bisschen eigen beim Essen, aber vertragen kann ich alles.
Brauchen Sie?
Ich habe nie geraucht.
Hab ich früher geraucht?
Nein, ich habe nie geraucht, habe ich gerade gesagt.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ach ja, mal so ein Bläschen.
Trinke ich schon ganz gerne, ja.
Wenn ich mich mit meinen Freunden treffe, wenn mal Besuch kommt,
dass man mal ein bisschen essen geht, dann trinke ich schon gerne mein Glasseck.
Trinken Sie?
Ach, das kann schon zweimal, dreimal in der Woche sein, ja.
Entschuldigung, für eine vorständige Krankengeschichte muss ich Sie auch Drogenkonsum fragen.
Was Drogenkonsum?
Also da brauchen Sie sich bei mir keine Gedanken zu machen, ja.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen oder chronische Erkrankungen?
Diabetes oder andere?
Ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, das hat man natürlich schon vor langer Zeitlässt gestellt.
Mein Herz ist auch nicht mehr so gut.
Ich huste halt ein bisschen, ich habe so ein bisschen chronischen Husten.
Da kommt aber eigentlich nichts.
Da habe ich immer ein bisschen mitzutun.
Da hat man festgestellt, dass ich Osteoporose ein bisschen habe.
Da hat man eigentlich auch mal festgestellt,
dann soll ich halt immer Vitamin D nehmen.
Versuche ich auch dran zu denken, denke ich aber auch nicht immer dran.
Na ja, und dann, ja sonst, halt nicht, sonst ist eigentlich alles in Ordnung.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein oder bei Bedarf?
Vitamin D haben Sie gesagt, aspirin, Sie haben gesagt?
Ja, aspirin habe ich jetzt gegen die Schmerzen genommen,
aber ich hatte auch vor vier Jahren mal eine Thrombose
und deswegen nehme ich immer, eigentlich jeden Tag diese 100er Aspirin.
Also eine am Tag, um für die Blutverdünnung halten.
Das soll auch für mein Herz gut sein.
Einmal morgens, oder?
Ja, genau.
Und dann nehme ich auch noch etwas für den Magen, glaube ich, das ist Omeprazol.
Und dann nehme ich noch Metaprolol, das ist, glaube ich, wegen des Humduedrucks.
Omeprazol wie viel Milligramm?
Oh, da kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen, was da drauf steht.
Ich weiß nur, dass ich da morgens und abends nur Tablette nehmen muss.
Metaprolol wie viel Milligramm?
Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Einmal, Metaprolol einmal, take a minute.
Nee, zweimal, morgens und abends.
Wo sind Sie früher operiert, irgendwann bei CHO-operiert?
Ja, ich hatte tatsächlich mal eine Krampfaderoperation
und als Kind sind mir mal die Mandeln rausgenommen worden.
Andere?
Sonst wüsste ich nicht.
Nee, sonst, ja, doch, ich hatte mal so eine Hautveränderung hier an der Wamme
und das hat man weggenommen mit so einer kleinen lokalen Operation.
Man hat dann gesagt, das war so ein Vorstadium von Hautkrebs,
aber das ist nie weiterbehandelt worden
und dann sollte ich danach ein bisschen mit der Sonne aufpassen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie eine Tromboise gehabt hat.
Wann und wo?
Das war vor vier Jahren und das war im linken Wein.
Sind Sie im Krankenhaus zu behandeln?
Nein, nein, ich habe halt meine Strumpfe bekommen
und musste Heparin spritzen
und dann hat man das nach einem halben Jahr kontrolliert
und dann habe ich die Strumpfe noch ein bisschen weitergetragen
und ja, jetzt habe ich manchmal noch so ein bisschen geschwollene Beine,
aber das Anziehen von den Strumpfen ist halt so mühsam,
deswegen ziehe ich die eigentlich zur Zeit nicht an.
Ich verstehe.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass Ihre Eltern gestorben sind.
Das wäre wunderschön, wenn Sie noch leben würden.
Haben Ihre Eltern irgendwelche Erdliche oder chronische Krankheiten
bemerkbare Krankheiten?
Mein Vater war am Ende des Dements, das weiß ich,
aber sonst wüsste ich nicht
und meine Mutter hatte tatsächlich Brustkrebs zum Schluss,
aber sie war erst im hohen Alter.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder
und der hatte tatsächlich so eine leichte Hirnblutung,
hat sich aber zum Glück ganz gut erholt davon.
Ja, ich freue mich dafür.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verwitwit.
Ja, aber die sind natürlich schon groß,
ich habe zwei erwachsene Töchter.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, die sind zwar nicht mehr die jüngsten,
aber soweit ich weiß, sind sie gesund.
Welche Beruf haben Sie geübt?
Ja, natürlich bin ich jetzt Rentnerin.
Ich war angestellte in einer großen Firma,
habe da im Büro gearbeitet.
Wie du kaufst?
Ja, ich hatte keine Ausbildung,
das war in unserer Generation noch nicht so,
aber ich habe dann halt im Büro gearbeitet
und damals hat man ja noch viel mit Maschinen geschrieben
und nicht mit dem Computer alles gemacht.
Da waren noch viel Handarbeit und viel Papier zu bewegen.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Husten haben.
Seit wann hausten Sie?
Eigentlich schon ewig lange.
Also in den Sommermonaten geht es ein klein bisschen besser,
aber sobald es ein bisschen kühler wird,
habe ich eigentlich so einen Dauerfusten, kann ich sagen.
Kommt auch Ausrüstung?
Nein, das ist eigentlich immer so ein Trockner-Husten.
Frau Schneider, ich habe Ihnen
alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich habe Ihnen jetzt so viel erzählt.
Also ich wüsste nicht,
Sie wissen jetzt ja alles über mich.
Was ich natürlich wissen will, wie es jetzt weitergeht,
dass wir gegen die Schmerzen machen und ob ich gleich nach Hause kann.
Ja, ich würde gerne Sie ganz genau erst mal untersuchen.
Danach würde ich gerne bei Ihnen
eine Röntgenuntersuchung durchführen.
Und natürlich würde ich gerne Blut abnehmen.
Und dann habe ich ganz genau
über Ihre Diagnosen sprechen.
Dann können wir über die Diagnose sprechen.
Gut, okay, ja, das klingt doch vernünftig.
Gut.
Na, gute Frage.
Wie bin ich ins Krankenhaus gekommen?
Also ich habe meine eine Tochter angerufen
und deswegen sind wir auch erst am Nachmittag gekommen,
weil die erst da Zeit hatte und die hat mich dann mit dem Auto gebracht.
Und hier in der Klinik
haben wir uns dann an der Forte vorne gleich ein Rollstuhl ausgeliehen
und die haben mich mit dem Rollstuhl dann reingefahren.
So bin ich in die Klinik gekommen.
So, gibt es noch andere Fragen?
Ja, gute Frage, ja.
Zum Kaffee habe ich noch
ein paar Kekse gegessen und das war so um drei ungefähr.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Leiden Sie unter Suicide eine Atemnot?
Ne.
Okay, danke.
Okay, haben Sie eine Schwellung, Rötung oder eine Erwärmung anbeimt?
Also ich könnte mir das ja nicht so genau angucken,
weil ich da nicht so gut hingucken kann.
Aber ich bin sicher, dass da eine Schwellung und Rötung ist, ja.
Da ist bestimmt ein fetterblauer Fleck, ja.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich weiß nicht, ob diese Frage gefragt wurde, aber
ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Ihr Fünfte
eine Verstellung hat oder
eine Verstellung oder
ja, ich weiß nicht.
Eine Verstellung, meinen Sie.
Ja, ab Norma, aussieht der Fünfte.
Ja, also so genau kann ich da nicht hingucken, ne?
Also genau kann ich da nicht hingucken, sagt ich ja.
Aber also, sie tut jedenfalls sehr weh
und ich habe eben auch dieses Taubheitsgefühl
und jetzt habe ich auch das Gefühl, dass ich das nicht
so richtig belasten kann, ne?
Aber vielleicht berühren Sie die Hüfte
eine Geräusche, vielleicht haben Sie gehört,
oder während des, ich habe nur meine eigene Stühnen gehört, ja.
Ja, okay, oder während des, ich würde vielleicht
haben Sie eine Knacken gehört, ja.
Da ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Nicht bebecken, ja, und plötzlich haben Sie ge-
Ich würde, okay, vielen Dank.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe ja, dass es real nie dazu kommt.
Ja.
Dr. Jüngerm, Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn Sie so weit sind, ne?
Danke.
Vielen Dank.
Guten Tag, Frau Oberast.
Mein Name ist Jüngerm.
Ich bin heute bei Ihnen als Assistant Ars-Tee-Tee-Tee-Tee-Tee.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patiente vorstellen.
Ja, wie haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ja, die ich auf der Notfall-
Aufnahme gesehen habe.
Haben Sie die gesehen? Ja, ja, wie haben Sie denn da gesehen?
Ja, Frau Alma Schneider,
78 Jahre Patientin,
das Geburtstatus
ist der 19. Dürritte
1947,
und sie ist 1,55 m
und wiegt
68 kg.
Die Patientin
stellte sich
in der Not bei uns
mit Rechten im Rechten
die Schmerzen im Rechten
Koksa vor.
Ja, gestern
die Patientin berichtet,
dass sie gestern
auf dem Weg nach Baden
gestürzt ist,
gestürzt habe,
danach
habe sie diese Schmerzen gehabt.
Die Bewußlosigkeit
die Frage nach Bewußlosigkeit
wurde verneint
und die Schmerzen
strahlen in der
Schmerzen
in den Oberchenkel aus.
Und
ja, in der Laufe da seid,
haben sich die Schmerzen
verschlimmet
und
ja, die Patientin
berichtet auch seit Langem
Wusten
und trockene Wusten
und
ja,
und die Patientin
in der,
die Patientin geht in der Not
einmal, zweimal zur Toilette
und da ist es auch passiert.
Ja,
da ist es auch passiert, ja,
weil sie auch die Toilette gegangen ist.
Ja, das ist normal.
Und die weitere Vegetative bei einem Mese
ist unerfällig.
Sie kontrolliert regelmäßig beim Frauenarzt.
Sie hat
alle beim Frauenarzt, ja.
Also, die Tricks untersuchen wahrscheinlich, ne?
Die Frage nach Tätonus-Impfung
in den 10 Jahren
wurde von der Patientin
verneint.
Die Patientin hat keine Allergie,
keine bekannte Allergie.
Sie raucht nicht.
Sie trinkt gerickfügige Alkohol
in der,
ja,
als Vorerkrankungen
haben die Patientin arteriell
Hypertonin, Osteoporose
und vor 4 Jahren
vor 4 Jahren
auch getretener
Pfotee,
Pfotee
und in der
Operation
einer Mese
gab die Patientin an
eine
Krampffader-Operation
in der Kindheit.
Wariko.
Ja, war jetzt die Operation.
Ja, und wegen
wegen einer
Hautkrepse
in Karlsruhe,
das heißt,
Basallium?
Ja, Basallium.
Eine Basallium.
Die Patientin
hat die Hautexzision
operiert,
operiert worden.
Ja, also ist sie mit einer Hautexzision operiert worden?
Ja, wie lange ist das her?
Ja, ich habe nicht frage,
wo war die Haut, wo war das Parallium?
Im linken Gesicht.
Im Gesicht, okay.
Ja, und die Patientin
nimmt regelmäßig
Acetic Scythysiose
100 mg,
Omeprosol, einmal
morgen,
Omeprosol und Metaprolol
einmal am Tag ein.
Und Vitamine auch regelmäßig
nimmt die Patientin ein.
Bay Bedarf nimmt die Patientin
auch Acetic Scythysiose
100 mg
Beidemars.
Ein.
In der Familie
Familiar Amnesi
gab die Patientin an.
Dass der Vater
der Patientin
hatte Demenz.
Ja, der Vater
der Patientin
hatte
eine Mama Karzinom.
Hat er eine Mama Karzinom?
Ja, hat er eine Mama Karzinom.
Der Bruder
der Patientin
hatte auch
Hirnblutung gehabt.
Aber jetzt
ist er gehalten.
Sie ist verwidert.
Habe Svagesunda Kinder.
Sie ist
Büroarbeiterin von Beruf.
Aber jetzt auch an die sichere.
Ja, das ist
meine Patientin.
Was ist jetzt Ihre Vermutung?
Ja, ich habe den
Verdacht auf
Vermutung
des Fraktüren.
Deswegen
möchte ich jetzt
eine Röntgen
im Kokosabbereich durchführen.
Was könnte
der Fernsehdiagnostisch noch dahinterstecken?
Ja,
als Differenzialdiagnostisch sind
Fernseh
Korpusfraktüren
oder
Sack
Sackro
Wirbelsohle
Ach, Wirbelsohle?
Ja.
Os ileum
oder die Fraktur
im
Pelvic-Bereich
kann sein.
Ach, okay.
Beckenfraktur.
Was machen Sie denn zunächst mal
bei der körperlichen Untersuchung mit der Patientin?
Ja, ich würde
erst mal
körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich achte
bei der Inspektion
eine Deform
das
rechten
Oberschenkel
oder Beckenbereich
eine Deformite oder Pirellung hat.
Ja, die Form
Deformation oder Prellung, oder
Was wäre noch erkennbar? Eine Kollegin hatte danach gefragt, die Patienten eine eindeutige
Fehlstellung, ne? Das wäre die Diformität. Ja. Okay. Und wonach gucken Sie noch?
Ja, ich untersuche auch bei der Parapation im Kochsbereich und Fremelbereich und Weckernbereich.
Ja, und was lösen Sie dabei? Ich kontrolliere Bewegungs-Bewerungs-Wink-Beweglichkeit.
Beweglichkeit. Ja, Beweglichkeit und auch natürlich Schmerzhaftigkeit, ne? Ob die Bestenkung hat oder
nicht. Und danach palpiere ich den Bauch auch. Ja, es kann sein, ja, abdominelle Probleme, kann
sein, vielleicht. Unsätzlich, oder wie? Ja, auf linken Seite, die Patientin sei in den linken
Seite gestürzt. Deswegen kann ein Leberprobleme... Okay. Ja. Okay, ja, was geht weiter?
Ja, ich auch palpiere, ich taste ich die, taste ich die Populität und tibiales Posterio und dorsales Pädis ab.
Um durch Blutung zu checken, ja. Und bei der Gelegenheit gucken Sie wonach noch? Ja.
Die Patientin hat einfach von Kompressionsstrumpfen erzählt. Ja. Sehen Sie nicht mehr an, Süd? Ja, wenn die Patiente
eine kompressionsschubdrüfte hat, muss man... Sie trägt die ja nicht, hat sie ja gesagt. Aber was hat sie erwähnt?
Er hat bei einem Idee, wenn er erwähnt. Ja. Nachdem sollten die natürlich auch gucken. Wenn Sie schon die
ADP und ADP checken, können Sie ja gleichzeitig bei der Gelegenheit nach den Fußgelenken auch
nach Knöcheltidemen gucken. Okay. Gut. Ja. Was machen Sie für neurologische Untersuchungen?
Ja, ich hab, ich würde gerne beim rechten Bein neurologische Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ob die Patiente eine Taupice gefühlt oder... Ja.
Wie nennt man das Ganze?
Sensibilität. Sensibilität für Hunger. Genau. Gut. Ja. Was geht labortechnisch und was geht
gerätetechnisch an Untersuchungen?
Ja, ich veranlasse erstmal Heparin, und weil die Patientin im Legen bleiben muss.
Okay, ja.
Deswegen. Und kann man auch Ultraschall durchführen. Ja.
Hematom für Hematom oder andere.
Hauptfälligkeit. Aber Sie haben auch der Patientin auch angekündigt, dass Sie ihr Blut abnehmen.
Was wollen Sie denn labortechnisch untersuchen?
Ja, kleines Blutbild. Blutgruppe. Ist wichtig. Das ja Blutzucker auch wichtig.
Und Leberwerte, Nierenwerte und Gerinnungswerte.
Die Erinnung wäre noch interessant. Ja, genau. Wenn die ASS nimmt.
Und Blutzucker ist natürlich interessant unter dem Aspekt, ob sie möglicherweise unterzuckert war in der Nacht.
Epogulitäminium.
Okay, gut. Ja, wenn sich tatsächlich rausstellt, dass die Schenkelheizfraktur hat, was ist dann die Therapie?
Therapie ist eine chirurgische Therapie.
Das heißt, das gibt es normalerweise.
Hyfte.
Hyfte, Küste.
Hyftep, Protease.
Total Endoprotease. Genau, eine neue Hyftep.
Und dazu ist das dann natürlich auch gut zu wissen.
Also Blutgerinnung.
Blutgruppe für den Fall, dass sie nachblutet unter der OP.
Und natürlich auch die Frage, wann sie zuletzt gegessen hat.
Wenn Operationsindikation jetzt sofort da ist.
Ja, okay, gut.
Dann schauen Sie bitte nach Froschneider, halten mich über den Befund auf dem laufenden.
Und dann werden wir die Patientin weiterverlegen in unsere chirurgische Abteilung.
Okay, gut.
Okay, schön, danke.
Ja, wir sind eigentlich immer bei den gleichen Sachen.
Zum Teil gibt es ein bisschen Verständigungsschwere.
Ein paar Sachen habe ich direkt korrigiert, haben Sie gemerkt.
Eine Sache, die mir jetzt aufgefallen ist, Sie sagen,
Sie ist auf die linke Seite gefallen.
Eine Sache, die Ihre rechte Seite tut ihr weh.
Insofern, da müssen Sie vielleicht ein bisschen aufpassen bei den Zahlen,
weil diesmal alles richtig.
Und ja, insofern denke ich mal, das war so weit alles in Ordnung.
Sie merken, dass Sie selber in dem Augenblick, wo Sie frei formulieren müssen,
wo eine Nachfrage kommt,
dass Sie da ein bisschen Formulierungsschwierigkeiten haben.
Da hilft eigentlich nur, sich gewisse Standardformulierungen zu überlegen
und sich denkbare Fragen einfach zu notieren und sagen, was sage ich,
denn wenn ich danach gefragt werde,
dass dieses Vorgehen, zum Beispiel, wenn der Patient sagt,
das ist schon gut, wenn Sie flüssig formulieren können,
sagen wir werden erst mal einige Untersuchungen machen.
Ich habe zwar Vermutung, aber darüber sprechen wir lieber erst,
wenn wir auch die Untersuchungen hinter uns haben,
die werden folgendermaßen ablaufen.
Dann kann man da schon mal so einen kleinen Vorbericht geben,
was das alles geplant ist.
Dass man auf alle Fälle auch so einer Patientin sagt,
wir müssen sie auf alle Fälle erst mal hier behalten
und genau gucken, was mit ihnen ist.
Natürlich muss man die Patientin in der Folge auch mal
radiologisch untersuchen, um zu schauen,
ob die nicht vielleicht doch irgendwie ein Problem hatte
und deswegen in der Nacht umgefallen ist.
Aber da gibt es ja verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Das ist ja eigentlich auch Standard-Verfahren dann in der Klinik.
Also wie gesagt, da so ein paar Formulierungen sich von vornherein zu überlegen,
was so denkbar ist, das wäre sicherlich vernünftig.
Ich finde es ja immer schlau,
erst mal auch tatsächlich noch keine Diagnose zu sagen,
haben Sie jetzt auch nicht gemacht,
sondern eben gesagt, wir müssen erst untersuchen
und dann kann ich zu Ihrer Diagnose Ihnen etwas erzählen
und dann gucken wir auch, wie wir sie weiterbehandeln.
Das ist klar.
Natürlich sollte diese Patientin in absehbarer Zeit
auch eine vernünftige Analgesiebe kommen, das ist klar.
Damit die erst mal ein bisschen runterkommt.
Und dann, das sind eigentlich so die Dinge,
auch wenn der Arzt Nachfragen hat,
dass sie sich da ein bisschen drauf einstellen auf Formulierung,
dass sie nicht ganz so doll suchen müssen.
Und was auch so ein bisschen eine Schwachstelle ist,
das wird aber eigentlich, also erlebe ich eigentlich immer wieder,
wenn ich so traumatologische Fälle habe,
dass der Unfallhergang eigentlich nicht richtig präzise beschrieben wird.
Sie haben gesagt, auf dem Weg zum Bad.
Die Patientin hat es aber hier eigentlich sehr schön ausführlich gestellt.
Sie hat gesagt, sie ist in der Nacht wach geworden,
musste auf die Toilette und dann ist sie gestolpert
über ihren Badezimmer-Teppich
und ist dann praktisch im Badezimmer gestürzt
und hat sich dann hochgezogen
an den Sanitär-Installationen da
und an ihren Handgriffen, die da angebaut sind.
Und so konnte sie sich wieder ins Bett schleppen.
Das muss man aber auch dann entsprechend ein bisschen schildern
und nicht nur sagen, sie ist hingefallen.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob Sie es gegenüber dem,
im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch erwähnt haben,
glaube ich ja, dass sie irgendwie schwindel oder Ohn macht.
Sie haben praktisch verneint hat die Frage.
Aber auch da kann man ja nicht sicher sein,
wenn jemand alleinstehend ist, kann das ja sein,
dass der Unmächtig ist und es gar nicht rafft.
Und gar nicht merkt, dass er da vielleicht 20 Minuten gelegen hat.
Und ja, na gut, wie auch immer.
Sprachlich sind tatsächlich eben noch Unsicherheiten da.
Die werden wir aber jetzt in der Kürze der Zeit nicht ausräumen.
Das ist einfach so.
Und was wir, was Sie noch ein klein bisschen vielleicht trainieren
soll, dass Sie auch für Ich-Fachtterminologie einbringen
in Ihre Schilderung.
Natürlich dem Patienten gegenüber nicht.
Der braucht immer die deutschen Begriffe
und eine einfacherer Wortwahl,
aber gegenüber dem Oberarzt,
im simulierten Arztgespräch,
sollten Sie schon auch versuchen,
dann die Fachtterminologie konsequent anzuwenden.
Gut.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen, für heute haben wir es geschafft.
Dann sehen wir uns alle.